so we've got to get back to this Anthony
foutch II story yesterday in 24 hours
this has completely exploded yesterday I
told you that increasingly Donald Trump
is listening to people other than
doctors I guess we would say dr. Anthony
Fauci the chief infectious disease
doctor of the United States who's been
working with presidents for 40 years in
the United States worked on the AIDS
epidemic etc etc doctor foul she
revealed that he had not even spoken to
Donald Trump for what now would be about
five weeks and that he is not briefed
Donald Trump on coronavirus in a serious
manner for two months I also told you
yesterday that the White House has put
out a list of things that foul Chi got
wrong in order I guess to discredit him
so clearly it was going bad meanwhile
Donald Trump has retweeted Chuck Woolery
and this is continuing to escalate I'll
get to the Woolery thing momentarily but
in just the 24 additional hours since
yesterday's show there now seems to be a
war this is crazy not between the White
House and the virus that's the war if
you want to apply war language here it
should be us versus the virus there
seems to be a war between the White
House and the government's own top
infectious disease doctor Anthony foul a
foul she just seems to be doing medical
stuff and the world is again crying and
laughing because the White House is
going after not the virus they're going
after foul Chi doctor foul she good for
him is no longer mincing words he said
very clearly the reason cases are
exploding is because we never completely
shut down and we're doing the wrong
things states that really came down were
fully shut down and stayed closed longer
others open too early here's the full
quote from doctor foul Chi we did not
shut down entirely and that's the reason
why we went up we started to come down
and then we plateau it at a level that
was really quite high about 20,000
infections a day then as we started to
reopen we're seeing the surges that
we're seeing today as we speak we made a
set of guidelines a few months ago
unfortunately it did not work very well
for us we can get a handle on that I am
really confident we
can if we step back understand that to
avoid having to fully shut down again
which it looks like some states are
starting to do you have to pull back for
a while you have to really limit things
what is going to turn around the case
explosion in Arizona Texas California in
Florida if you don't shut now shut down
California has extended a shutdown to 30
counties now including LA County in six
weeks hopefully we will see the positive
effect of that it takes a while these
other states are barely doing a thing
what will turn it around the heat hasn't
turned it around you know whatever else
they said was going to turn it around
has not meanwhile instead of working
with dr. pouchy the White House is now
fully on the offensive against doctor
foul Qi the guy who worked 40 years
under Republican and Democratic
presidents whose ideology is health he
is the target of trumps attack he is the
target of the White House's opposition
research the White House released a
document to media outlets meant to make
doctor foul Qi look untrustworthy with a
list of things foul she got wrong notice
Trump got wrong in April in March
actually we have 15 cases which will
soon be zero foul she is reportedly
referred to by some at the White House
as dr. doom and gloom
apparently foul she is not pleasant
enough about a hundred and forty
thousand people dying foul she isn't
upbeat about 60 to 70 thousand new cases
a day another report alleges that Donald
Trump is reportedly rattled by the fact
that the country continues to trust
doctor foul Chi more than they trust
Trump on coronavirus you know we talk
about ignorance in this country a lot
the country doesn't seem so ignorant
that they would trust the reality show
host president over doctor foul Chi on
matters of infectious disease and part
of this as we know Trump doesn't like
anybody else getting positive attention
but it gets even crazier because Donald
Trump's director of social media dance
Covino posted a pejorative cartoon about
doctor foul Chi that refers to him as
dr. Fawcett dr. Fawcett who wants to
turn off the faucet on everything so to
speak
so they're essentially attacking doctor
foul Qi I guess because he's being too
cautious essentially the White House
seems to be attacking doctor foul Qi for
not being more fun about a hundred and
forty thousand US deaths a number that
in all likelihood in the next few days
is going to start accelerating more
quickly as we saw it do during the
weekdays last week the White House has
gone to war not with the virus but with
the doctor fighting the virus so what
what I suggest what I think we have to
do is we have to step back here
recognize that this is part of the ant
in anti intellectualism in this country
where you can only trick the population
into continuing to just live a
completely normal life as if nothing is
going on when you have a lot of
uneducated and uninformed and ignorant
people and while on the one hand it's
good that doctor foul Chi is still more
trusted than Trump because the virus
spreads virally even if only 15 20 25 30
percent of the country thinks it's fine
to just do whatever the hell you want
that's enough to perpetuate one of the
worst
trajectories when it comes to cases in
the world now secondly the idea that
we've just had too much shutdown we
can't tolerate it anymore
recall that many states never shut down
fully because there was no national
shutdown Trump insists oh I shut it down
and now I'm opening it back up Trump
never shut it down it was States that
decided what they had to do and many of
them barely shut down we might now
actually need a national shutdown if
things don't turn around we're going to
talk also later today about Trump's
failings in terms of polling in Texas
but once again this could have been a
political windfall for Donald Trump he
just had to say listen we're in it
together listen to the doctors it's
going to be tough but this is what we
have to do I trust the doctors let's do
what they say we'd be better off fewer
people would have died Donald Trump
would be cruising to re-election right
now very different scenario five months
into coronavirus that we actually see
and now Donald Trump has been relegated
to retweeting conspiracy theories from
game
show host let's talk about that next let
me tell you real quick about one of our
sponsors cuts clothing they offer super
quality men's t-shirts and they're
giving you 15% off when you go to david
pakman.com slash cuts that see UTS
because solid color t-shirts are a
really important staple in pretty much
every guy's wardrobe I think it's really
important not to overlook the value of
having t-shirts you love wearing
t-shirts from cuts clothing have been a
game changer for me and as a company all
they deal with are men's
solid color t-shirts so they actually
put a ton of thought into the comfort
the style the durability of the t-shirts
they make they fit perfectly they're not
scratchy they don't shrink they don't
fade they don't stretch out over time
like so many other t-shirts they're
really the most comfortable t-shirts
I've owned and they look great this
right here that I'm wearing on YouTube
is the split hem crew neck t-shirt very
soft fits me perfectly it's the ideal
length go take a look at what they offer
and once you have it you are really
going to see and feel the difference
their slogan is it's the only shirt
worth wearing you will see why and
you'll get 15% off when you do it by
going to david pakman.com slash cuts
that's david pakman.com slash c UTS